so i want to i want to talk to you about
uh cancel culture and how it affects
media companies notably
that uh one of the sponsors for the
post-millennial where you are the
editor-in-chief yes that's right surf
shark
which is a vpn i believe right
they got somewhat some antifa guy
tweeted at them that andy no was all
these stupid things right they lied
about and surf shark immediately was
like
oh no shocked emoji we're so sorry we'll
immediately terminate our relationship
with them that's right so i i called him
out immediately i'm like dude and it was
all lies against andy it was none of it
was true if a but here's here's the
point i made this is really really
important
surf shark responded to me they said hi
tim cast we're not supporting or
dismissing anyone our core goal is
protecting people's digital privacy and
security and we just don't want to be
involved in someone else's conflicts or
ideological disagreements which is a lie
surf shock you're liars you're bad
people because when antifa tweets at you
and then you say you got it buddy we'll
sever ties with a business over your
ideology you're doing exactly that and
now that you're getting backlash for it
you have the nerve to come out and be
like we're not doing we're not we just
don't want to be involved
no
serve shark violated the privacy of the
post-millennial and andy now by publicly
tweeting they would terminate a business
arrangement over accusations made online
if they're willing to sacrifice or
violate the privacy look if they wanted
us ever they could have privately called
up and said guys we're not fans of this
conflict so we're not going to publicly
call you out on anything but we don't
want to work with you anymore that would
be private instead they publicly said
yeah look at those guys they're bad guys
we're not going to work with them
so
that's me calling them out but i'm
curious because i still saw ads on the
post millennial and uh i was wondering
if you had some more insight into
this uh
spineless company selling out their
values out of fear from antifa
yeah it was actually pretty interesting
and shocking so it was basically
you know one tweet at this company um
saying that andy is a violent person
which i don't know if you guys have ever
met andy but he's like the furthest from
a violent person uh that i've
almost ever met um
and then they said that they weren't
doing that they they terminated our
relationship with them but then they
said that or they actually did
they're not working with us anymore
because i still saw like like a week
later there were still ads for it yeah
it was the lag oh
so the the this this company
actually terminated a business
arrangement because some random
antivirus oh he deleted his tweets by
the way yeah he tweeted lies yeah then
they went
no problem he took it down um but then
also
uh
oh yeah
yeah the ads came down a couple days
late
we were busy apparently i'm hearing
after
um but they wanted them removed but yeah
so we took the ads down um
and you know they basically
gave legitimacy to these violent
extremists who wanted to
silence the media median silence the
press
but going but so and they actually you
know they replied to customers too and
we have screenshots of this as well
because andy reached out on twitter and
was like hey if you hear from them
um and we have screenshots they they
told customers that andy was you know
violent and we weren't going to be
working with they weren't going to be
working with us anymore because of
auntie there were a lot of people on the
right who said they've worked with surf
shark mm-hmm yeah i mean i i think that
they're i think this is a horrible thing
to do i think it's a horrible company i
mean that shows that they don't actually
care right they're only responding to pr
issues yeah wow and it's really just
this one person said this thing
oh yeah no it's all nonsense i mean so
where do you where do you guys see the
sort of oh i'm only doing business with
a certain type
of political ideology going like do you
think that it's going to move into like
a polarized corporate system it's going
to be
i mentioned this before like parallel
economies but i think people need to
boycott and tell all their friends and
family to boycott
and the way i see it is if a company is
willing to
defame someone
privately and publicly
then
whatever it costs them in pr to run
those ads it should cost them 100 times
from the power of the people to say
you're bad and we reject this and then
going out and telling everybody because
i'll tell you this
people don't rem you know there's this
old saying i can't remember exactly but
it's like this advice you'll get and
media like a negative experience is ten
times worse you know it or it's like a
thousand times worse than a positive one
a positive experience is expected a
negative experience is infuriating so if
someone goes into your restaurant and
they order a cheesecake and it's a
delicious cheesecake they'll be like wow
that's so good well of course it should
be they probably won't give you a good
review they won't share your your
restaurant don't tell their friends
about it but if you have a cheesecake
and it like is gross they'll tell
everyone they know
so if these companies want to play this
game where they're willing to step up
stand up and shove themselves into an
ideological conflict and and i'll
mention this too andy is the editor at
large theater at large yeah so to sever
their business arrangement over one
employee right and to violate the
privacy one editor we have a lot of
editors too yeah i mean and we're
keeping our legal options open because
this was clearly defamation
yeah
defamation and libel and what
for every instance of it is it another
instance of libel for every person that
they can't yeah like every time they say
it every person they told
lies about andy and by saying that
they're yeah and by saying that they're
not getting involved they are very
clearly getting involved on the side of
this guy who you know just has it in for
andy because andy exposes antifa all
over the place and is very honest about
it and works hard at that we got to get
the post-millennial monetized with uh
minds
bill's like i'm not joking i'll make a
business move yeah let's do it follow up
yeah actually you told me the other day
you were like hey yeah yeah you got to
figure that out so i changed my password
because of course i couldn't find
anything and i found that somebody had
given me tokens all right that's money
so that was fun in the bank
you know there was a period where i said
i was like
a few years ago i'm like oh hulu did
something woke i'm not going to boycott
because they said something dumb i'll
come you know i'll tell them it's dumb
i'm well past that point i'm like
if a company comes out
and
does something like this which is
substantially worse than just posting
stupid you know
nonsense if they actively defame people
and enter the conflict i say go nuclear
share it with your friends share my
tweets with everybody tell everyone you
know anybody who has the service no
we're not going to work with you we're
not going to buy the same thing for
amazon
what what did when amazon bans people
yes all the time no i know but are you
are you boycotting amazon
uh that's a tough one half
half but you're right it's a good point
i actually started there were some
things that i was ordering on amazon and
i actually started ordering them from
the company specifically i'm not going
to say it because what if they say they
hate me and then i can't order their
stuff anymore but there's uh it's
interesting what you were saying about
the parallel
economies because we switched you know
we switched mostly from using youtube
for our podcasts and stuff at
post-millennial and now we're using
rumble for everything
and it's you know just fine and we like
them quite a bit
it's a lot you know
this is what we're talking about
culture and like in terms of creating
more culture
what is going to happen
are there going to be fully parallel
economies with different services based
on ideological perspectives yes and if
so
you know where's the conservative amazon
part of it too is that the uh the
non-left-wing side of things doesn't
always do as great a job
you know what you know the issue they
don't have all the graphic designers
they don't have all the creatives you
know so what's going to happen with that
it is changing it's yeah it's definitely
changing and i think yes where's the
conservative to launch an amazon
marketplace i would i would buy from
them
didn't mike lindell try doing something
i feel like that's again is you're going
too far it's like where's the apolitical
place launching yeah the alternative you
know because it's like when you're here
where's the conservative alter it's not
oh it's like you don't just go to the
other side you know it has to be the one
that is well hold on there for everybody
what what i'm saying is
where the conservative side is the side
that allows you to sell karl marx and
hitler the left side is the site that
allows you to only sell karl marx and
that used to be the last year
you could say conservative or maybe it's
an apolitical free speech supporting
that's right wing bro
you can but you're falling into the trap
no no no no free religion are on the
right wing no no no no that stuff's
beyond political parties it used to be
it's still not detailed you can't have
it if you're gonna divide you guys can't
happen
and unwilling to accept if you're going
to allow yourself to play a game that
you already lost right joe rogan is
called alt-right bill maher is called
it's not joe rogan is called far right
and the dude's literally in favor of ubi
doesn't mean it's real dumb people are
using those terms
left and right don't mean anything and
never really did other than are you in
favor of the revolution or opposed to it
so yes if you oppose the left's woke
revolution you are the right republican
republican democrat don't mean anything
it's just a thing you tick it's no
different
republican and democrat refer to the
parties you don't necessarily know your
right wing you do not accept that you're
right i have repeatedly said in terms of
the culture war i would be considered on
the right you would be considered but
that doesn't mean that that's what you
are
let me finish michael malus has
described this as the new right new
right personalities and his position is
ask someone this question i'll ask you
do you believe that some people are
better than others of course not
you don't think so that's well that's
the left position
the right the new right position is okay
well i sort of miss interpreting it
depends on what you mean by better
better better
are are is one human life more valuable
than another exactly so that's how i
interpreted michael are some people
michael's more ethical than others yes
what michael said is the left will
opine and and and justify and the right
will simply say yes
so here's here's the issue
in terms of the
the political compass my political
ideology leans left in terms of
cooperative you know i know right
libertarians don't like the idea but
cooperative meaning non
non-transactional more like i i'll help
you if you help me it doesn't really
scale up all that well so mostly i defer
to positions of liberty
however in the culture war i believe in
free speech i believe in religious
freedoms i believe in bodily autonomy
those things do not exist in any facet
on the left okay so maybe that's too
absolute maybe there's some people on
the left who are calling this out but
look at aoc going to the met gala with
her tax the rich dress where a guy
carries it for her while wearing a mask
she is not that that's that's that's the
hero of the progressive left then you
look at the social the libertarian
socialist youtubers and streamers who
are celebrating rule by decree
if you when you come out and and you're
speaking
colloquially in modern culture
the
free speech
freedom of association the right to read
any book you want is considered
right-wing
yeah i don't disagree but that again
it's sort of adopting their paradigm
to to accept that right i suggest we do
instead
just erase those words from your
right and left starting and saying
i'm happy to say liberty liberty is fine
and if people are going to associate
that with the right that's their
decision but you know liberty's not
going to get taken away and from the
language
part of the problem i think is that we
need to be able to communicate with one
another and so we need to share words
and those words need to have common
definitions do you not think that
liberty is a more effective word than
conservative or liber i mean i don't
want to say libertarian because
libertarian i know a political party but
liberty i think i i don't think is
co-opted
so you would say
you are i'm not i'm not i'm not making
the new term i don't know
but
i mean i've heard the the concept of
liberty minded i think is is cool but
you know there's there's different words
that can achieve it without
having that association i think the what
draws music left concept of you know
yeah
yeah but we can't define ourselves in a
neg as a negative right right why do you
need to define yourself pro-freedom i
mean come on who like
you're right that that will be
associated with the right but that is
actually
dude the gadsden flag
has one simple meaning
liberty
leave me alone yet
they they the the the antifa people have
a flag of the snake of the the communist
fist killing the snake squeezing it out
when when
if you go so i have friends
who are
the left
they will tell you outright they are in
favor of the state taking away your
freedoms so we can say freedom they'll
still say in the media in every
newspaper right wing
yeah that's
that's fine let them do that
the interesting thing i suppose is that
like on my wikipedia for instance says
i'm both left and right and they're like
i don't know it's like his
anti-corporate politics are fairly
left-wing and it's like left and right
don't mean anything other than tribal
signifiers at this point
like uh i think left and right can
probably broken down very very simply do
you question the narrative or do you
blindly follow it if you blindly follow
it that's what we consider left
if you challenge it that's what's
considered right wing so even if your
positions are like pro-choice
tax the rich universal health care ubi
and you challenge official narrative
they'll call you right wing i just think
there's a lot of people on the left that
don't want that to be the case the
freedom you know at the freedom sect of
the left they don't want that so that's
what's the freedom sect to the left
there is you know it's there the
the
uh anarcho communist the libertarian
socialist i know you know
where they're when the libertarian
socialists are following prominent
individuals who celebrate rule by decree
and the communists are fire bombing
small businesses i'm not they are just
lying about what they represent
i don't know
i don't know i don't i don't want to
give up hope that there is you know a
group of
people you know on on that end of the
spectrum that do care about values that
that matter when gamergate happened
a lot of these people started posting
their political compass tests and they
were all left libertarian
now they're all like center center right
that happened to me i used to i
been taking those those little you know
cosmo testers of
political affiliation and it used to be
like all over here and now it's over
here but it's the same stuff like i'm
i'm voicing the same opinions they're
changing the algorithms yeah to make you
think that you're in some kind of club
or labeled some certain way to divide
you like don't play the game don't say
left and right don't put people in camps
and say they're conservative and this
because then they're going to use that
to destroy the cults yeah they'll
destroy each little cult the
conservative cult the liberal cult the
left cult the right they will target
that sect of things that we've created
inadvertently we want to let ourselves
lazily do it so don't do it
people want to be affiliated with each
other people want to be part of groups
it's understandable that's our in our
genetics to survive yeah i mean where
there's one called gone too far species
there's there's one institutional cult
and that's it um we're not a hive
species
no we're like um new york city looks
kind of like a hive sometimes yeah but
we i don't think humans are necessarily
hive animals we're more prepared
animals yeah and and to identify tim i'm
so sorry i didn't even understand what
you just said because i was in the
middle of that conversation with libby
what did you just say you said you
started pointing out like the
conservative cult in this cult there's
only one cult oh
yeah obviously there's like cults they
exist but
independent voters and republicans are
challenging the narrative republican
voters expressed disdain for the
republican party democrat voters
overwhelmingly believe whatever they're
told by but micah brazil from the other
perspective rachel maddow fox news is
the narrative that no one is blind no
from the other perspective no yes it is
on narrative and there are things
when when tucker carlson came out and
said sidney powell was wrong they lost
like three million viewers do you wanna
do something i was on his show that what
that night and i lost so many twitter
followers that night because i was on
the show where he slammed sydney powell
but they still retained millions of
viewers and still is the biggest show
because people on the right are not
they're individualists they're they're
not unified for the most part though
there are different groups within the
right that make it up i'll put it this
way the the
no i forgot the analogy i was going to
use anyway the point is
the the left as we know it the ones that
are pro vaccine mandate the ones that
believe trump colluded with russia the
ones that never let that go they refuse
to believe the facts when stories come
out and say like biden did this
mark milly
called china outside the chain of
command all of this is the story is
developing being confirmed
now we have the defense secretary saying
i never authorized that now we have the
defense secretary saying if trump gave a
military order it should not be going to
to mark milly
we know for effectiveness and what is
the mainstream narrative he was a hero
who stopped a madman that is the cult
that they can tell you to your face
they've shuddered the three branches of
government they have bypassed the
standard process of legislation and the
the priests of this the so-called
libertarian socialists are celebrating
the the usurping of civilian authority
the usurping of the branches of our
government
they're in a cult now if republican
voters like if trump voters republican
voters and independents argue with each
other all day and night but agree on
certain principles of freedom clearly
not a cult because i can have an
argument with somebody about like jack
the other day about family and
responsibility and we're not unified but
we'll hang out we'll have more shows and
we'll debate these ideas
look at what the left does on their
shows you can't challenge them brian
stelter won't have on glenn greenwald to
question him in any capacity but tucker
carlson brings on antifa all the time
thanks for checking out this clip from
the tim cast irl podcast if you want to
see the full show come back to this
channel youtube.com tim cast irl monday
through friday at 8 pm where you can
leave comments and super chat and we
actually will read your comments on the
show don't forget to like share
subscribe and if you want exclusive
members only content segments you can't
get anywhere else go to timcast.com
become a member and we even have full
bonus episodes thanks for hanging out
and we'll see you all next time
you